le thon rouge c'est bon dans les sushis
hans beck est pour satisfaire les
consommateurs
l'espèce est victime de surpêche dans
les années 90 certains pays alerté sur
l'industrialisation de sa pêche le ton
au milieu d'une polémique les suédois
ont essayé lors de cette conférence à
kyoto de faire interdire la pêche trop
industriel mais sans succès notamment
face aux japonais la même année en
france les pêcheurs particulier deux
tons rouges constatent eux aussi les
conséquences de la surpêche
alors combien du temps depuis début de
la journée pas malheureusement et
comment vous expliquer ce que pratiquent
les pêcheurs provoqué un large débat il
des baléares c'est-à-dire pêcher dans
les prières c'est sûr que ça détruit
dans les mains de poisson mais le thon
rouge et la poule aux oeufs d'or de la
méditerranée les consommateurs en
veulent toujours plus et face à cette
pêche intensive les associations
écologistes craignent une extinction de
l'espèce alors dans les années 2000
première prise de conscience avec
l'instauration de quotas pour le thon
rouge en méditerranée et en atlantique
freiné en plein élan
les pêcheurs ont du mal à comprendre
d'un jason schenker prochaine du port
qui va disparaître
pourquoi qu'est ce qui ce qui va vous
menacez conquête yvonnou monassier on
aura plus d'équipages parce que c'est
pendant quatre mois de saison comme
pourra maintenir des équipages les
quotas sont fixé à 32 mille tonnes pour
2006 29 1500 tonnes pour 2007 et 28 1500
tonnes pour 2008
pas suffisant pour protéger l'espèce
répondait les associations écologistes
en 2006
colère aussi des écologistes selon eux
pour bien faire il ne faudrait pas
pêcher plus de 15 mille tonnes de thon
rouge par an
pour pêcher toujours plus certains
armateurs français n'hésitent pas à
aller très loin au large des côtes
libyennes où les quotas sont une notion
lointaine
les quotas continue de diminuer pour
arriver à 12 milles 900 tonnes au niveau
mondial en 2011 grâce à ces quotas le
stock de thon s'est régénéré parole de
pêcheurs maintenant vous mettez votre
palangre n'importe où vous pêchez ça
devienne ça devient ces jardins s'agit
là des plus en plus de temps parce qu'il
ya de plus en plus de temps
conséquence les quotas sont revus à la
hausse regardez il était de 12 milles
900 tonnes en 2011 pour passer à 23 1655
town 2010 est un appât du gain au
détriment de la survie d'une espèce
estiment les écologistes et les thons
rouges ne vont pas être laissée
tranquille de sitôt car les quotas pour
2010 neuf sont de 32 mille deux cent
quarante tonnes et pour 2020 de 36 mille
tonnes soit 4 tonnes de plus qu'au début
de la mise en place des quotas
[Musique]